I favor ending Birthright citizenship
for the kids of illegal immigrants in
this country thanks to each wave of new
arrivals to this land of opportunity
We're a nation for every young we build
hundreds of miles of border wall
and despite what's said here today we
reduced illegal immigration and Asylum
abuse by 90 percent rather than making
them or talking about putting up a fence
make it possible for them to come here
legally with a work permit and when they
go on to go back they can go back and
they can cross and open the border both
ways this border is going to be a day
one issue for me as president we're
going to declare it a national merch yes
we'll build the wall if we ever close
the door to new Americans our leadership
in the world would soon be lost Joe
Biden should not be on the picket line
he should be on the southern border
working to close our Southern border
anyone from any corner of the alert of
the Earth can come to live in America
and become an American